hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my flash Supergirl crossover video
there were a whole bunch of comic book
Easter eggs because this was definitely
like a love letter to the fans just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet the way they designed it you
didn't really need to be super familiar
with the flash or super familiar with
Supergirl that both helped and hurt the
episode just a little bit for reasons
that I'll explain one of the things with
Supergirl because it's on a major
network is that they don't try to get
super specific with the science of it
all if you really like them getting into
the minutiae of things like that that's
really what the flash TV show does
because team flash is based at STAR Labs
it's largely a science-based show Easter
eggs though the flash versus Supergirl
in a footrace there have been about ten
times that Superman has raced the flash
it hasn't always been the Barry Allen
flash but because our Flash right now is
Barry Allen this was a love letter to
the world's finest comic where they did
race there were five different comics
that Superman raced the Barry Allen
flash in two of those were world's
finest so obviously you get the title of
the episode the Supergirl episode was
called world's finest but just to have a
little bit of extra fun another Easter
egg they changed the apostrophe like
when it's world's finest in the comics
they're just talking about the single
world like this single world's finest
but because the flash is from another
earth they're talking about the
multiverse it's multiple worlds finest
for the episode title so a lot of you
might have been confused about Barry at
the beginning of the episode it looked
like he had a Harrison wells tachyon
device attached to his chest just like
the reverse-flash had during season one
well during the next episode of the
flash they're presumably going to
explain that in how he accidentally
jumped parallel dimensions but because
the production schedules of both shows
didn't line up perfectly the flash
explainer isn't happening till after
this episode of Supergirl so it's a
little out of sync it kind of sets but
whatever so flash enters the episode
auto-saves Cara and they had that scene
where they're basically explaining that
none of the characters from arrow in the
flash exist on supergirls earth like you
have central city but you don't have
STAR Labs you don't have Cisco you don't
have Caitlin you don't have Black Canary
you don't have Oliver Queen any of these
other characters so that should answer
your questions about alternate versions
of arrow flash characters on supergirls
earth none of them are there
don't they don't exist at all and
there's no Supergirl on earth one or
earth two doesn't know lot of you asked
that question
the Supergirl exists on arrow or flashes
earth and maybe they just haven't found
her yet no they'll just explain that
either she hasn't made it to earth yet
or she doesn't exist at all in that
universe cat grant when she's trying to
name Barry calls him the blur that's
what they used to call Clark on
Smallville before he got the Superman
name they just called him the blur they
do explain a little bit about silver
banshees backstory like she's not born
looking like that in the comics that is
not makeup that's what she ends up
looking like normally wants her powers
manifest the way her powers manifest in
the comics is a little bit different but
it's kind of the same deal where she's a
friend of supergirls but then an attack
from her father makes her powers
manifest and she ends up taking the
mantle of silver banshees so it's like
the past that you can't escape from the
family the family history that you try
to run from that literally comes back to
haunt you
so in the episode she kind of embraces
that she'll be like this but the way
they explained it on the TV show I
wasn't really happy with the way they
explained her outfit weight you need a
makeover first I was like wait what did
she actually say that was that a line of
dialogue you have to remember this is
CBS this is largely written for a female
audience a really young female audience
so I forgive it some of the overly cute
dialogue and because it's a flash
crossover they were just trying to have
a little bit of extra fun with him in
the scene with the firefighters at the
end I get what they were trying to do
Supergirl does the Superman thing wins
back the people's trust by almost giving
up her life to save them the
firefighters are the one to take down
silver banshee and live wire using
fourth grade science just like oh she's
giving off all this electricity well
just hose her down that'll take care of
her but it all just felt a little too
saccharin like if you feel like the
flash is a really bright and happy show
Supergirl is like three cups of sugar on
top of that there were a couple
important things that Barry did before
he left if he didn't catch it
he helped them develop a way to keep
metahumans locked up so that they don't
have to take them back to the de Oh
every time they capture one on the flash
TV show they just call it the metahuman
wing of iron Heights prison so they have
a version of that on Supergirl now I
think one of my favorite Easter eggs
though was when Barry was explaining the
multiverse Winn was like what about an
earth where you're all evil and Barry's
like I've been there
it sucks in the comics earth-three is
crime syndicate earth it's literally an
evil carbon copy of the Justice League
but in the context of the Supergirl
episode
Barry was talking about earth to earth -
on the flash TV show is like earth 3 in
the comics otherwise though most of the
Easter eggs were just internal things
for things that happen on previous
episodes of the flash like when
Supergirl is telling him about losing
the public's trust because she went all
red kryptonite Barry kind of had the
same thing during flash season 1 during
the flash versus arrow episode where he
got dosed by rainbow Raider cat grant
did break the fourth wall she had like a
Deadpool moment when she said the
attractive yet non-threatening cast of a
CW show which is totally true watch any
CW show that is what they go for when
they cast actors so let me know in the
comments what did you think about the
episode do you like the idea of the
flash crossing over with Supergirl do
you want to see her come on arrow in the
flash
she probably just come on the flash
first but now that they're connected via
the multiverse really anything is
possible anything that they would want
to try to do they have said that if it's
a rating success that they will do the
same thing next year they'll have
another crossover and they'll probably
try to bring Supergirl on to the flash I
don't know what the story would be but
we probably won't hear about that till
comic-con they tend to announce really
big stuff like that at Comic Con like oh
yeah we're gonna have a really big
crossover with these other shows it's
gonna be amazing so if you like the idea
of all these shows crossing over they're
definitely gonna keep doing it because
it actually is pretty successful but
what's gonna happen next is I'm super
far behind on a bunch of other videos
there's a new episode of the flash be
sure to subscribe to get everything the
DC giveaway is still going on all
announced the winner of that whenever I
post my flash video why you guys wait
for that video to post you can click
here to learn all about the Batman vs
Superman
Justice League scene that they just
posted and you can click here for all my
Batman V Superman Easter eggs thank you
so much watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight